ich bin wahnsinnig gespannt auf diese
Diskussion weil wir wirklich mal ein
paar ganz grundsätzliche Dinge
diskutieren wollen vorher aber erstmal
Heizungen muss heute sein vorgestern
Einigung im heizungsgesetz was hat ihr
Ministerium dazu beigetragen gut wir
sind dabei wir sind natürlich involviert
aber die Hauptverhandlung liegt ja jetzt
auch im Parlament das haben sie ja auch
mitbekommen und ich finde es sind sehr
wichtige Durchbrüche erzielt
also Wasserstoff
ready was passiert wichtig war in diesem
Gesetz ja dass wir eine
technologieoffenheit haben das heißt wir
wissen ja heute noch nicht wie in 20
Jahren unsere Netze aussehen werden wie
die Wärmeversorgung in den Kommunen
aussehen wird deswegen jetzt die
wärmeplanung anstoßen und natürlich auch
die Optionen offen halten dass unser
Ziel Klimaneutralität erreicht werden
kann aber das kann eben mit Wasserstoff
das kann mit Pellets das kann mit ganz
verschiedenen Wegen erreicht werden wir
unterstützen indem wir den Wasserstoff
hochlaufen also Deutschland zu einer
wasserstoffrepublik machen können mit
Forschung damit eben Wasserstoff besser
produziert effizienter produziert werden
kann Lieferketten stattfinden und
Angebote Nachfrage zu sein also Pellets
können wir gleich abräumen gibt ungefähr
600.000 glaube ich Pellets Heizungen die
ist in Deutschland gibt mehr oder
weniger so eine Zahl ich im Kopf habe
interessanterweise ein gewisser Winfried
Kretschmann betreibt auch eine Pellets
Heizung zu Hause Wasserstoff wann werden
wir ernsthaft mit grünem Wasserstoff
darum geht's ja mit grünem Wasserstoff
heizen
das ist eine Frage wann die Netze
ausgebaut sind und es ist die Frage wie
schnell wir Angebote Nachfrage zusammen
bekommen wir sind ja alle unterwegs
weltweit wird er jetzt das Wasserstoff
die Wasserstoffproduktion angestoßen wir
brauchen Partner deswegen auch das
Reisen wir brauchen wir haben ja in den
letzten Monaten gesehen die wichtigsten
ist dass wir nicht von einem Land
abhängig sind sondern dass wir weltweit
Partnerschaften haben mit wertepartnern
insofern geht jetzt darum dass wir
heimische Produktion aber wir haben
natürlich von den Standortfaktoren her
nicht die besten Voraussetzungen wenn
der Wind und Sonne anschauen sondern
international Partnerschaft mit den 70%
werden wir importieren wir wollen unsere
eigene Leistung verdoppeln bis 20 30 und
den Import dann mit den Partnern
zusammen organisieren wir ernsthaft mit
Wasserstoff heizen wenn wir jemals mit
Wasserstoff heizen
das ist ja ich gehe davon aus dass wir
auch mit Wasserstoff heißen werden sie
müssen das doch wissen ja aber nein nein
moment mal doch Wissenschaft
Wissenschaft und Forschung hat etwas
damit zu tun dass man nicht in glasguckt
Google schauen kann wir haben Optionen
Moment einmal muss ich ja meinen
Gedanken machen wer hat denn schon die
Zukunft vorhersehen können ähm einstein
hat gesagt wir werden niemals die
Atomenergie nutzen
ja wir bleiben bei Heizung was ich ihnen
damit illustrieren will ja dass die
Frage was wann genau kommt das ist
natürlich etwas was trial and ever
Prozess ist wir wissen aber das
Wasserstoff die Technologie funktioniert
wie schnell wir jetzt den Hochlauf
hinbekommen weil wir die letzten
Forschungsfragen klären müssen also wie
werden wir effiziente wie bekommen wir
elektrolyseure in die serienfertigen die
bauen wir die Netze das ist alles jetzt
in der Plan ich kann Ihnen heute keine
genaue Zahl sein aber es wird kommen Sie
eine Idee
auf die Faktoren drauf an wie schnell
jetzt auch andere Länder Australien
Südamerika irritieren finden dass sie
als bundesbildungs- und
Forschungsministerin und das Mitglied
der FDP die das ganze Land in dieser
Wasserstoff ready Frage jetzt monatelang
vor sich her getrieben hat
eigentlich nicht wirklich verbindlich
ungefähr sagen können wann das läuft
nein nein überhaupt es geht ja nicht nur
um Wasserstoff weil die alleine es geht
ganz technisch wissen Sie ich habe jetzt
eine Heizung zu Hause und jetzt stehe
ich vor der Frage brauche ich mir jetzt
eine Wärmepumpe ein Ja oder rüste ich um
die alte ist kaputt und dann sagt die
FDP pass auf Erlösung für alle
Wasserstoff ready so hat das keiner
gesagt
aber der Eindruck vermitteln ist doch
eigentlich es gibt eine Lösung
wahnsinnig wichtig ich habe mit ihrem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Christian dürr
viel mehr das ein oder andere Gemetzel
geliefert genau zu dem Thema und er sagt
der Wasserstoff ready das ist das Ding
überhaupt technologieoffenheit natürlich
so das klingt so so entspannt
das ist nicht entspannt sondern es ist
die Grundlage dafür dass wir die großen
Probleme nicht nur auf einem Weg lösen
sondern auf den vielen Wegen weil die
Herausforderung zu groß sind nur auf
eine Wärmepumpe setzen ich habe
persönlich überhaupt nichts gegen eine
Wärme nein ich habe keine Wärmepumpe
weil ich eine Heizung habe die schon ein
bisschen älter ist insofern ich habe
aber nichts gegen Wärmepumpe und jetzt
eine genaue Zahl zu sagen das ist glaube
ich der falsche Weg die Hauptsache ist
wir halten uns den Weg offen wir haben
ja schon gesagt dass wir bis 2030 unsere
produktionsfähig unsere unsere
Kapazitäten in Deutschland verdoppeln
wollen aber natürlich wird viel auch aus
dem Ausland importiert sein und deswegen
die Strategie die ihr jetzt auch in den
letzten Zügen ich habe einen schönen
Satz für Sie Vorschlag warziger wie und
in welchem Umfang Wasserstoff in der
Wärmeversorgung eingesetzt werden sollte
ist allerdings umstritten laut dem
kopernikusprojekt gibt es vor allem
Wärme Sektor zumindest was Gebäude Wärme
betrifft bereits heute deutlich
effizientere Alternativen zum Einsatz
von Wasserstoff wo habe ich das gelesen
haben sie eben gerade heute gesagt das
habe ich das ist etwas was in unsere
einem unserer Projekte wahrscheinlich
ja genau und das wird dann auch auf
unsere Homepage gesetzt aber dort steht
auch heute das haben wir nicht schon
alles wussten wir dass wir in einem Jahr
haben
da steht bereits heute gibt es
effizientere Alternativen schon jetzt ja
natürlich heute aber wir wissen dass wir
den Wasserstoff brauchen um in unserem
Land den Industriestandorten unsere
Energieversorgung
aber deswegen muss ich doch nicht nur
Option zu machen Herr Lanz wir beide
wissen nicht was in fünf Jahren genau
ist aber diese Option auszuschließen
wäre der falsche Weg warum mache ich
eine Tür zu ohne Notwendigkeit
die Frage ist ob diese Tür jemals
aufgeht Frau stark das ist doch der
entscheidende Punkt die Frage ist doch
nicht ob man die Tür zu macht die Frage
ist ob die aufgeht
brauchen ein bisschen konkreter weil
sonst sonst sind wir so in abstrakten
Bilder mit vielen offen obwohl ich mag
Bilder aber
wir sehen jetzt das Wasserstoff ein Teil
unserer Energieversorgung sein wird
warum weil wir mit Strom nicht alles
werden versorgen können und vor allem
weil der Strom ja wir werden noch
bessere Batterien haben aber wir
brauchen ein Speichermedium und deswegen
werden wir in Zukunft mehr Wasserstoff
haben und das Interesse ist groß auch
diesen Wasserstoff zu produzieren weil
viele Länder die uns bisher Öl und das
verkauft haben ein neues Geschäftsmodell
brauchen und deswegen haben hier auch
mit Australien eine komplette
Lieferkette schon einmal jetzt
vereinbart Australien ist in den Hafen
einfahren und uns den Wasserstoff
bringen aber natürlich ist die Frage da
haben wir wussten wir das ein Krieg
kommt wo wir schneller werden konnten
nein wussten wir nicht das heißt Ihnen
jetzt heute sozusagen 2040 oder 2038 das
wäre einfach unsere Lieder aber es wird
kommen noch mal haben sie nicht Angst
dass sie da gerade eine gigantische
Wähler Enttäuschung produzieren Florian
Biberach sagt ihm was das
Geschäftsführer der Stadtwerke München
wird zitiert mit dem Satz es ist nicht
absehbar dass wir bald große Mengen
grünen Wasserstoff haben wir werden
Stadtwerke München werden erst natürlich
ist der grüne Wasserstoff ja noch mal
die Krönung des Wasserstoffs im Markt
hochlaufen mit alternative regenerativer
Energie hergestellt ein erneuerbaren
Energien hergestellt insofern aber ich
finde es auch gut dass es
unterschiedliche Meinung gibt aber noch
mal warum soll ich ohne Not eine
Möglichkeit Zeit eine Energieversorgung
die klimaneutral ist und die vielleicht
auch besser eine bessere Option ist wenn
sie Mehrfamilienhaus haben wenn sie
Etagen was auch immer warum soll ich
diese Option nicht ermöglichen das haben
sie mir bisher noch nicht erklären
können ich sage Ihnen was anderes die
politische Dimension wenn das nicht
funktioniert und Menschen kaufen sich
jetzt zu Millionen Wasserstoff ready
Heizungen was sagen Sie dem wenn
irgendwann dieser Kunde Wasserstoff
einfach ausbleibt weil er vereinbares
vielleicht können Sie mal als schildern
wie Sie das sehen weil er für die grüne
Stahlherstellung gebraucht wird weil er
für Verkehr Flugzeuge große Schiffe und
so weiter gebraucht wird weil wir gar
nicht in der Lage sein werden so viel
Wasserstoff herzustellen wie wir
brauchen was machen wir mit dieser
Wähler Enttäuschung die dann entsteht
und der Frage welche Heizung baust du
dann ein wenn du vorher geglaubt hast
irgendwann kommt dieser ominöse grüne
Wasserstoff von dem jetzt die Stadtwerke
München schon sagen eher nicht ich finde
dass die FDP hier tatsächlich eine
komplette Irreführung der Wählerinnen
und Wähler betreiben mit diesem Begriff
Wasserstoff ready denn unter diesen
vermeintlichen Begriff der
technologieoffenheit wird hier
suggeriert man könne sich Gasheizung
einbauen und die werden dann irgendwann
vielleicht von Zauberkraft Wasserstoff
ready sein und dann kommt dieser
Wasserstoff ohne Frage wir brauchen
Wasserstoff aber eben tatsächlich um
eben die energieintensive Industrie die
wir ja in Deutschland haben weiter
betreiben zu können und zwar grün
betreiben zu können ja und diese
diese diese
Suggestion dass das jetzt dass das jetzt
in für die Heizung tatsächlich gebraucht
werden könnte also für den privaten
Gebraucht die eine komplette Irreführung
aber ich möchte jetzt mal sagen
Irreführung finde ich jetzt schon sehr
harten begriff was steht denn oder was
wird im Gebäude Energiegesetz stehen da
steht ja nicht drin du musst dir eine
Wasserstoff bei die Heizung einbauen
sondern deine Kommune wird eine
wärmeplanung machen
und je nachdem wie die wärmeplanung
aussieht wirst du dich dann entscheiden
können welche heizheizung für dich das
Beste ist und das ist auch der richtige
Weg ist zu tun und die Option dass wir
auch Wasserstoff dort einsetzen die
sollten wir nicht aufgeben mehr ist das
nicht und deswegen ist es keine
Irreführung sondern es ist ein
zusätzliches Angebot aber die
Entscheidung muss ich dann treffen wenn
die wärmeplanung folgt ganz
grundsätzlich weil immer wieder mit so
Begriffen hantiert wird Kernfusion zum
Beispiel die große Frage woher kommt die
Energie der Zukunft was würden Sie sagen
wann sind wir soweit wann wann haben wir
Kernfusion der große Traum also wir
sehen im Augenblick sehr große
Durchbrüche und ich möchte noch mal eins
sagen weil wo sehen Sie die
wir haben an der National indischen
facility gesehen dass eben zum ersten
Mal mehr Energie erzeugt wurde durch
Kernfusion also durch Fusionsreaktion
als reingesteckt wurde wir haben in
Deutschland sehr viel Kalorien genau
und wir haben ja bei uns in Deutschland
sehr viel magnetfusionen wir haben das
Max-Planck-Institut für Plasma Physik
hat in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern den
Wendelstein das ist der modernste
magnetfusionsreaktor den es gibt auch
dort hat man Durchbrüche gehabt mit
positiver Energieversorgung wir haben
mit den Wissenschaftlern eine Roadmap
entwickelt um zu sagen die Rollen wir
jetzt den nächsten Schritte aus nein
diese Energie wird nicht morgen zur
Verfügung stehen
gesagt in 10 Jahren da steht vielleicht
ein erster Demonstrator in Deutschland
weil es auch da wieder eine Menge Leute
aus ihrer Partei gibt die sagen wir
müssen offen sein technologieoffen da
wird diese Kernfusion kommen das löst
alle unsere Probleme und weil ich heute
die große habe mit der
Forschungsministerin mal zu sprechen sie
sagen da steht vielleicht ein einsamer
Generator in zehn Jahren oder so also
ich würde sagen man kann ja mal die
Wissenschaftler sprechen und das ist
eine große Option unseren Energiemix
nochmal zu revolutionieren wenn
die Grundlagenforschung der letzten
Jahrzehnte sich auszahlen und wir sehen
dass die Ergebnisse die ersten
Ergebnisse vorliegen in 10 Jahren ein
langer Weg aber nur weil sie heute nicht
da ist heißt doch nicht dass wir da
nicht weiter dran forschen diese riesige
Chance nehmen wissen Sie auch warum weil
der Wettbewerb um uns herum ja auch
wieder stattfindet wir haben eine tolle
Grundlagenforschung die Frage ist wollen
wir jetzt die Kommerzialisierung
woanders lassen oder wollen wir selbst
den Transfer machen der Kernfusion
beherrscht und Kernfusion hat hat einen
riesigen Wettbewerbsvorteil und deswegen
müssen wir dahin investieren das ist
eine riesen Chance ob ich das jetzt in
der Flächenversorgung noch erlebe das
weiß ich nicht aber darum geht's auch
nicht sondern es geht darum die Chancen
für die Zukunft weiter auszubauen also
sie haben diese zehn Jahre genannt jetzt
Rudern sie zurück und sagen da gibt es
vielleicht diesen einsamen Generator
ganz kurz wenn ich mit Physikern hier in
der Sendung spreche sagen die mir vor 30
Jahren läuft da gar nichts das ist
wirklich dann Kraftwerke in großem
Stiele am Netz gibt
immer zu Ende wir müssen auch mal
ambitioniert sein und uns große Ziele
setzen nein in den USA will man schon
viel früher ein solchen Demonstration
Reaktor haben wir sprechen jetzt auch
mit der Wirtschaft weil wir brauchen
jetzt den Schulterschluss um eben den
Transfer auch gut und schnell zu machen
aber noch mal finden Sie es lauter
sozusagen mit all diesen Schlagwörtern
immer zu arbeiten nicht jetzt die
persönlich Vorschlag weil sie ja bitte
ne geht nicht um sie aber die Position
ihrer Partei
technologieoffenheit das ist genau das
Wasserstoff freddy ist genau das und in
Wahrheit stellen wir gerade fest den
Grünen Wasserstoff wird es in der Menge
so schnell nicht geben vielleicht wird
sie noch nie geben wir stellen gerade
fest die die berühmte Kernfusion in zehn
Jahren gibt es vielleicht den ein oder
anderen kleinen Reaktor irgendwo aber
ansonsten vor 30 Jahren spielt sich da
nichts ab also ist das in Ordnung das
den Leuten sozusagen ständig sofort zu
kauen und zu tun als wäre die Lösung
unserer Probleme quasi um die Ecke
müssen nur noch einmal kurz drumherum
gehen
Sie uns in den in den Mut was so nicht
stimmt es ist ganz wichtig dass wir
jetzt die erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen
dass wir planungsbeschleunigung machen
dass wir all das was dann Potenzial ist
auch wirklich nutzen es wird aber in
einem Land wie Deutschland nicht
ausreichen wir brauchen für den
Industriestandort eben den Wasserstoff
und deswegen hat das nichts mit etwas
versprechen zu tun es ist eine
Notwendigkeit das ist das fehlende
Steinchen im Rahmen der Energiewende
und genauso müssen wir auch schon über
heute und morgen hinausschauen weil
natürlich wenn man die Fusion darstellen
könnte das ist ein unheimlich intensiver
Energieträger dann hätten wir die
Energieprobleme in Deutschland gelöst
nicht nur in Deutschland sondern
weltweit weil wir haben ja auch die
Herausforderung dass um uns herum die
Länder ja auch eben die Transformation
schaffen müssen und deswegen können wir
auch nicht an unseren Grenzen aufhören
den Blick das heißt diese Zukunftsoption
Fusionstechnologie wo man jetzt sieht
dass die Grundlagenforschung sich
auszahlt die müssen wir nutzen insofern
ist das eine gute Kombination zwischen
jetzt ihr Erneuerbaren plus den
Wasserstoff und dann die
Zukunftstechnologien die Kombination die
sie machen ist eine andere
sie sie versprechen den Leuten Dinge von
dem wir gerade festgestellt haben die
werden so schnell nicht kommen die
könnten kommen
in zehn Jahren wieder ein und dann
gucken wir ich hoffe dass wir dann beide
im wohlverdienenden Ruhestand sind aber
nein
wie auch immer ich will nur sagen die
Kombination ist auf der anderen Seite
versprechen sie den Leuten genau das und
auf der anderen Seite sagen sie das
Verbrenner aus verhindern wir AKW lassen
Sie mir bitte weiterlaufen
Tempolimit verhindern wir auch es bleibt
alles wie gehabt
Mission wir haben eins der
ambitioniertesten
klimaschutzprogramme in unserem Programm
stehen wir wollen nämlich mit dem
Zertifikate Handel mit einem klaren
Deckel wie viel CO2 ausgestoßen werden
darf und einem Abbau Pfad der hätten wir
klare Ergebnisse wenn wir das sehen was
in der Vergangenheit war
Bundesrechnungshof hat gesagt er hat die
teuerste und ineffizienteste
Energiewende
gelegt mit Mikromanagement mit
Programmen wo man gar nicht weiß wie
viel CO2 am Ende eingespart wird das ist
weniger effizient als das was wir wollen
und insofern innerhalb dieses Rahmens ob
das jetzt der Wasserstoff ist ob das die
Erneuerbaren sind das wird die
Entwicklung zeigen insofern ist das ein
sehr ambitioniertes Programm und zwar
mit einem klaren Ziel
ich und das ist ja heute sozusagen ein
bisschen das große Thema der Sendung die
Frage wie erneuerungsfähig sind wir
eigentlich wirklich
gesagt wenn ich das so höre meine andere
Frage nehmen Zusammenhang wäre wir
brauchen ja Leute die sind großartige
Technologie von der wir alle jetzt hier
so begeistert sind die müssen die
entwickeln
Leute dafür brauchen Leute wie ein
schmiedhubert aber wir brauchen eine
richtige brillante Köpfe
digitalpakt Schule
2019 beschlossen 5 Milliarden Euro
stecken da drin
wie viel sind davon abgeschlossen also
die Mittel wir haben die fünf Milliarden
es waren ja hinterher noch zusätzliche
Pakete da ging es um die Corona
die sind das ist alles abgeflossen die
Mittel die abgeschlossen sind Ende
letzten Jahres ich habe jetzt noch keine
aktuellen Zahlen die werden sicher
demnächst kommen abgeflossen sind ca 1
Milliarden Euro
aber Herr Lanz die Mittelbindung ist
fast ist über 90 Prozent das heißt die
Projekte sind in der Planung sie dauern
mit der Umsetzung okay finde ich das gut
nein aber das ist die Realität okay 2019
beschlossen 5 Milliarden der große
Kraftakt jetzt wird dieses Land digital
eine Milliarde ist abgeschlossen nicht
mal ein Viertel Frau war es wie finden
sie das das ist ein komplett die
Desaster tatsächlich dieser digitalen
Schule ja denn die Ziele sind verfehlt
worden eigentlich sollten schon 2021 3,5
Milliarden abgeschlossen sein um noch
mal zu erklären was heißt denn
abgeschlossen das heißt dass das Geld
dann auch tatsächlich in den Schulen
angekommen ist die Schulen also damit
arbeiten können dass es auch bei den
Schülerinnen und Schülern dann ankommt
wie viel Mittel jetzt sozusagen schon
mal gebunden sind heißt ja nicht dass
das da schon tatsächlich einen
Fortschritt passiert und der wird ja
eigentlich dringend gebraucht sie haben
es jetzt ja gerade schon beschrieben wie
groß eigentlich die Bildungskatastrophe
in diesem Land ist das ja vor so großen
Herausforderungen
steht und das Fatale ist dieser
digitalpakt ist ja bis 2024 ausgelegt
eigentlich müsste er jetzt schon an
digitalpakt 2 gearbeitet werden aber
auch das passiert eben nicht das ist
nicht absehbar das heißt wie laufen da
wirklich so in ein Loch hinein und die
Schulen brauchen Planungssicherheit
künstliche Intelligenz darüber reden wir
heute auch
3 Milliarden Förderung von der alten
Gruppe noch beschlossen
wie viel
ja also es ist ja über verschiedene
Häuser verteilt das sind 5 Milliarden
insgesamt eine Zahl die jetzt ja auch
erhoben wurde das wirklich abgeschlossen
ist sind 1,3 1,4 Milliarden wenn ich
mich jetzt nicht auf die die
Nachkommastelle festlegen
aber natürlich von 5
ja abgeschlossen aber lassen Sie mich
auch mal was dürfen sich an einer Zeit
fest und ich kann Ihnen sagen vielen
Dank
ich kann Ihnen sagen natürlich ist das
jetzt ein Thema wo wir Gas geben müssen
erstmal möchte ich vielleicht darf ich
noch sagen wir verhandeln am digitalpakt
2.0 also vielleicht das zur Sache ist
aber jetzt noch mal zu der kalten wir
haben eine ki-strategie damals
vereinbart und ist läuft auch schon mehr
als die 1,3 Milliarden zeigen wir haben
100 KI Professuren schaffen wir haben
Infrastrukturen geschaffen das auch
mittelständische Kapazität dass die auch
mal etwas die haben ja nicht unbedingt
Rechenzentrum bei sich wir haben
Nachwuchsgruppen geschafft also da ist
einiges am Laufen ist das genug nein das
ist eine Grundlage auf die wir aufbauen
können wir müssen jetzt noch viel
schneller werden und vor allen Dingen
auf die neuen Entwicklungen reden
wirklich wollen wir da wirklich richtig
rein also sie als FDP sie sind ja nicht
nur Wasserstoff ready sie sind ja auch
sie sind ja auch in Digitalisierung
Partei das heißt der FDP müsste doch
dieses Thema ein echtes Herzensanliegen
sein oder nicht das ist es auch ist es
ja das ist es habe einen schönen Satz
für Sie in diesem Jahr sind für
ki-projekte 3 830 Millionen Euro
vorgesehen im nächsten Jahr soll es dann
nur noch 630 Millionen sein im Vergleich
für die Erweiterung des Kanzleramts wer
nach derzeitigem mindestens 777
Millionen Euro fällig und dann der
schöne Satz Berlin denkt offenbar lieber
in Beton als in Bits und beiß wissen sie
von wem dieser Satz ist
ich habe zu meiner Linken richtig
geschrieben und es ist brillant auf den
Punkt gebracht was eigentlich das Thema
ist
ja also tatsächlich muss ich erst mal
sagen die Ampel selbst hat sich ja gar
keine ki-strategie gegeben sondern die
ki-strategie ist 2018 von der damaligen
großen Koalition verabschiedet worden
mit einem sehr ambitionierten Ziel
nämlich Deutschland weltweit führend zu
machen in künstlicher Intelligenz so
dann hat die Ampel quasi diese Strategie
geerbt und anstatt die jetzt sich noch
mal vorzuknüpfen hat sie die verbummelt
verschlafen ja wirklich verpennt muss
man sagen ja und wir sehen ja gerade mit
Chat GPT und der neuen generativen KI
ähm dass wir eigentlich das dann das ist
ja ein echter wake-up call aber Berlin
scheint sich da im im Tiefschlaf zu
befinden und ich verstehe einfach nicht
dass man jetzt nicht dass man einfach
weiter macht wie bisher dass man sagt
diese Mittel sind so vorgesehen ist wenn
jetzt sogar weniger Mittel
Digitalisierung kai ist doch kein Gedöns
was man einfach so auf der linken
Pobacke irgendwie absetzen kann sondern
Deutschland muss ich wirklich anstrengen
damit wir da nicht bummeln letzter
werden im international Wettbewerb